now to madagascar and a government
minister there is being hailed as a hero
and an example to follow after surviving
a helicopter crash at sea
swam for some 12 hours before he was
rescued the police minister had been
helping search for survivors after a
cargo ship illegally carrying 130
passengers sank off madagascar's
northeastern coast
fishermen who set out before dawn
spotted someone in the water
exhausted and still in his wet uniform
madagascar's police minister recorded a
message
i'm alive and well
in 24 hours i can be back at work
i'm not injured but very cold
i'm thankful to the people of mambo for
saving my life and taking care of me
[Music]
the fisherman brought the 57 year old
safely back to shore after he spent 12
hours at sea
another survivor an air force mechanic
managed to swim the entire way to the
beach
the body of one other man in the
helicopter has been recovered
but the pilot remains missing and is
presumed dead
authorities say the cause of the
helicopter crash has yet to be
established
the minister says something suddenly
destabilized the helicopter potentially
causing it to go down
our mission was over
we saw the accident and we were about to
go home
but like all accidents something
unexpected happened
our helicopter may have been caught in a
gust of wind or something and fell
the helicopter was one of two taking
part in a search and rescue operation
after a small cargo ship sank on monday
an official said the ship was overloaded
from carrying too many people